when Sigourney Weaver gets fourth
billing and then William Hurt gets fifth
billing no you're done DUP no matter who
the first three names are most people
dismiss the village including me but
let's at least acknowledge the solid
visual flair which is not an accident as
Roger Deakins was the DP on this movie
which many people seem to forget
including me so am i sitting the movie
or myself or you guess what I don't even
care
Wow emotional moment here I want to show
respect but also what skinny-ass grave
dug just behind him cannot hold the
coffin he's crying over a smoke monster
on the Prairie and these ladies hate
flowers in the funny that's funny my
college girlfriend said the same thing
when she found my old also I think part
of the reason people tired of Em's
formula is scenes like this that
prioritize mood over authenticity no
group of kids no matter what cult no
matter how brainwashed stands silently
in a perfect circle around a dead animal
there are just too many varieties of
immature human nature at play for one of
them to not run away screaming yell for
an adulterer try to gross everyone out
by using it as a hand puppet those we
don't speak of have not breached our
borders for many years they do not come
to make the bubble it's great again I
will gather new medicines and I will
return how does he know for sure that
the new medicines exist
this movie's gonna hates dogs keep
careful watch over our little ones as
they play on the hill or maybe don't let
them go play on the hill unsupervised
even those we don't speak of are much
larger creatures than coyotes those we
don't speak of you actually speak about
their asses all the goddamn time maybe
the least believable thing in this
entire movie is that there is only one
clothesline for this house basically
full right now and it's only drying one
outfit I mean holy I guess this might be
how they did pants back in the whatever
time period these fools are trying to
stay in but I don't care sitting that
pants and belts have a very specific
relationship and this outfit is breaking
all the rules in unholy ways you may run
from sorrow as we have sorrow we'll find
you this is what my college girlfriend
said to me you right before our first as
these boys run away from the forest do
two weird noises can't help but notice
how the entire town is just candled the
out of itself tonight does anyone sleep
did these boys sneak out for a forest
edge adventure just after supper when
everyone's still awake every other
window has a lit candle this game is
more tough than anything else in this
movie which is saying something why is
this one tree in the foreground acting
like it's fall and its leaves are all
brown and mostly gone but all the trees
in the background are green and full of
life and showing no signs of autumn
whatsoever oh so she's blinding a blind
protagonist some lazy ass writing if you
ask me kind of an asshole or writes a
story even pending sequels about a blind
protagonist considering we've basically
spent the first 20 minutes of this movie
watching just the boring parts of Little
House on the Prairie I think I'm the one
who's having their time stolen Ron
Howard's daughter is that the school
bell Jeanie today at resting Rock Noah
Percy handed Ivy Walker berries of the
bad color berries of the bad color is
all of the following a new nickname for
bruised testicles the name of my grunge
revival band a popular spicy Albanian
Cola drink and the title of the
unauthorized biopic of The Cranberries
secrets of this village and candles
sometimes we don't do things yet others
know we want to do things so we don't do
them basically this is the book of
Romans from the Bible boiled down to a
single sentence he uses the same amount
of caution walking into the forbidden
wood that I use when walking into
Wendy's which is to say not nearly
enough weird his view of the creature
the ground ends at the midpoint of that
tree on the left and he couldn't see
anything left
that nor turn his head to see extra so
he's walking back and I guess he made
there's no cuz that cut about did the
projection has put a reel out of order
just lost twenty minutes a movie right
there
Christ sir that coolness though Hass
dropped somewhere along line path to
hearest skip when you just care for my
sister deeply I said skip damnit wait
this is thirty seconds later and she's
still talking about this I swear if you
took the conversation bosses out of this
film you'd be left with about twenty
minutes of actual dialogue I am blessed
as well my older sister is now spoken
for I'm now free to receive interest
from anyone be careful what you wish for
also anyone is being generous there are
like a dozen age-appropriate eligible
males here and at some point in breeding
becomes a problem for a community like
this no these Redcoats are a nice
attempt at sleight of hand by M night
trying to distract us with a mini twist
to hide the main twist but the problem
is by this point we're also trained to
look for his twists that we know what
he's doing the moment we see the poster
for the movie our looking for the twist
basically kills the effectiveness of
them it's basically Schrodinger's twist
the bell then everyone hurries to the
sellers and again I'm left wondering how
many of these adults would find this
mythology worth all this effort when you
just pay a couple of dues to patrol the
perimeter and do creepy and whatnot to
keep your myth alive I know why I'm
being rhetorical if you only need this
for the boovie viewers not for the story
or the characters which kind of sums up
the problem with this movie you wrote it
for moments and gave logic and reason
the finger while doing so still
surprised that I don't see more of those
we don't speak up cosplay at comic-con I
mean who doesn't want to dress up as
little red porcupine hood these fucking
assholes thought they needed to have the
boogeyman show up inside the town on
someone's porch to have its mythos be
believable it helps sell the ruse to
movie viewers but inside the world of
the movie itself there's no sensible
reason to do this and in fact this only
risks your ruse being exposed actually
what if the human inside trips and the
cloak falls off and they're all pointing
like look at it has been Benjamin all
along
they use X wahkeena so the monster can
figure out front doors to houses but not
doors in the floor who has written this
note no one admits it but she still
stands up to read it as evidence which
is stupid how do you even know it's real
but also why not ask the gal that handed
you the note who handed it hurt then
asked that person who handed it to them
so on and so forth till you find the
writer or the note
neither actors in character here this is
literally William Hurt telling Adrien
Brody his performance is over the top
and please give it a goddamn rest for at
least one scene Christ if you can do
shorter runs of tables why in the name
of those who do not speak up do you
create one mile-long table in the middle
making it impossible for anyone to walk
anywhere during this meal for fellowship
or exercise or delivering extra food to
tables
oh no no no lenders tell me after all
the lies and fear theater and wasted
effort tell me it didn't throw out a
perfectly good hunk of pig some kind of
sacrifice to the fake monsters tell me
you didn't waste that bacon why the
ceremonial tossing could have just taken
two steps and drop that down the rock
but you had to do a three wind up cliche
toss you an out to feed the beasts and
you took two small children with you I
had an inner sister mrs. clack you've
been keeping secrets movie has time for
this movie has time for so much of this
most casual wedding ever
people were talking throughout and look
how many were in the green house and not
even pretending to pay attention they're
all terrified of red monsters in the
woods but not all these fucking candles
casually threatening to send them all to
hell in a quick 30 seconds
this also goes on for some time no lie
I'm going to take a sit off of this
movie for the love story between these
two and its authentic portrayal even in
the midst of all the silly there in the
village what the heck is that a young
pre and middle axle delivering the roll
credits moment roll credits I realize
you want some light to see where you're
going and let your Wayne but this is
basically the here we are please come
eat us highway no the hides and feathers
are missing their marks on the door was
opened this scene suggests only a select
few adults here know about the ruse
which is balls that's insanity to a tee
just like in the prestige sooner or
later you're hired actors playing the
boogeyman will realize they can make
demands and or you die without passing
on the ruse details and the whole thing
falls apart
honestly watch this movie once and you
might be forgiven for thinking it was
kind of cool watch it twice and you will
have questions sir hi coyotes reached
obviously you haven't seen Acme's latest
line of ladders no insomnia I just
called outside baby it's cold outside do
you find me too much of a tomboy not at
all
you were asking him not me um let's see
what he says in response were you
married will you dance with me
Germanic Pixie dream girl can you not
say what is in your head why can you not
stop saying what is in yours oh snap
Lucius would be brutal at cinemasins
zing away Meryl zing a wet there's a
fine line between love and stalking and
this character kind of embodies that
line there's nothing you could do that
would sacrifice my love for you
holy that is a scarf to end all scarves
they only got two takes before it ate
her this movie psycho moment is not as
impactful as a movie it's stealing from
hell did you drag the rocking chair all
the way out to the edge of the yard and
leave it in the rain yes miler why would
you do that barely even rocks out there
there really isn't much you can see
there that you can't see from the cover
pork yeah but if our lives are actually
a movie the director could use it as an
ominous shot following the tragic effect
Oh true carry almond no Percy was found
four quarts of blood
on its closing hey anyone that speakest
whose it is why are you assuming it was
a person after everything that's been
happening with the skinned livestock
popping up wouldn't the first thought be
that it was animal blood somehow
everything in this movie goes on for
some time considering she handed her
cane off before commencing with the
bitch-slap beatdown how did she know
where he'd put it as she grabbed forward
on her way out you have gone out of your
way to show me we are deep into autumn
but now you want your kale and your
leafy greens to be in full perfect
harvest condition behind this
husband-wife discussion and I'm just
thinking you people have never grown
anything in your entire lives you are a
strong one you others would follow which
is weird since you raised her in a
society you created to condition people
to follow it's ironic really very best
not to scream or and I'm just
spitballing here you could prepare her
for what she's about to experience with
the gift of spoken language use your
words William use of words you needn't
be scared we have the magic rocks Oh
also magic rocks ultimately Christoph
goes back to the village because he's
afraid and not because he just recently
got married and has a wife to impregnate
I mean take care of as murdered by
numbers and gwen stacy sit here in the
freezing rain I'm left wondering why the
truth was so important it needed to be
told to her but still kept from him and
then now departed krysta something in
these woods turns my stomach to rot
that's anxiety because of all the lies
your parents told you about these woods
and if you just hang on a bit we will
get you some modern meds for that that
will turn your life around some you
better and these was the most boys
anyone would say so
oh just can leave you coward stop
spewing transparent excuses for being a
coward you are literally leaving a blind
girl alone in an icy forest to save your
own skin
you sir are more evil than Darth Vader
also with no modern compass and no
sunshine good luck not getting lost in
frostbitten ass face I cannot explain in
words Oh bold of the Thunderbolt here
try these words it's a costume we wear
to scare the villagers into not going
into the woods to find out it's actually
the 21st century was that so hard the
creatures are fake man he's telling her
this because she's determined to go into
the woods looking for towns with
medicine my first question is why not
tell her no then go to town your own ass
and get the medicine keep the lie alive
and not risk the blind daughter's life
seems perfect to me
but for that nebulous and non-binding
sounding elders
mentioned earlier my second question is
she revealed this to her like this you
could have told her then told her again
and then when she requested proof you
let her touch this thing
boo Bob's your uncle you're done but
instead you let her feel it first for
maximum shock and pain because you don't
love your daughter you love creating
dramatic moments just like your director
forgive us our silly lies ivy they were
not meant to harm you your lies are not
silly they were foundational to her
understanding of life they were
restrictive and intentional and
basically a prison you don't get to call
your lies silly president Satan Faceman
puppet master you go with two escorts
the fact that it must be the blind girl
who goes for help and no one else is one
of the most baffling things about this
movie this is ultimately presented as
the elders that knew about the truth all
along and that is way too large a group
for this to have lasted 40 years without
issue protected here innocence
said the guy that just sent his blind
daughter on a quest through the woods
how could you have sent her she's blind
I said this ages ago lady so your
audition for cinemasins is a wasted
effort of all the things that go on for
some time in this movie that's climbing
out of a hole is that goes on for some
timing us they did exist
rumors of creatures in these woods
remember a shit even this goes on for
some time actually the village could
have probably just been titled this goes
on for some time the movie look if the
tension is working for you all this
might work as well but if it's not it
just feels like can we please get to the
obvious twist is obvious part of this
thing so we can all go home you a movie
he's Adrien Brody a mentally disabled
person so him cropping like this is
weird but him standing cinematically in
a field of leafless red berry plants
surrounding him like blood spatter
that's beyond weird
that suspension of disbelief killing
impossible he found one of the suits we
kept under the floorboards
and not only do we get that giant
steaming pile of convenience but he also
somehow understood to put it all on
perfectly escape the room find his way
into the woods without being seen and
track down Ivy who had a giant head
start oh and not to mention when he
found her he ran after her without
making any noise or saying her name even
though he's likely clueless as to what's
coming on just know it's getting since
two by two it's a gruesome death yes but
I'm definitely glad he's dead that
character sucked allmovie long dams
where the wild things are adaptation is
much darker than I anticipated his will
to live is very strong worst bird box
challenge ever it was a 21st century all
along so
let's examine this idea show me strap in
this may take a while it appears as if
it's been about 20 years since they
moved here and in that time they've
developed an entire off-grid
self-supporting community without any of
the kids finding out since lucious is
already born in this picture they
basically had two or three years to make
it happen went on him having some
memories of the outside world all the
homes the clothes the food everything up
and running ridiculously fast also as
unlikely as that is to happen what makes
it even more ridiculous is the size of
the community what are there like a
hundred people here when did the others
arrive how did they hear about it with
each new family the secret becomes much
less likely to be kept and what about
the wood where are they getting the
lumber for these picnic tables the
houses especially considering the
central key to their religion is to stay
out of the King woods what about noises
anyone who has lived out in the boonies
know she can hear sounds from miles away
there was no possible way they haven't
heard a horn honk or car backfire or had
to explain off the explosions in the
distance every 4th of July and that's
just the things they don't even try to
explain even the explanations are
nonsense they bought a wildlife preserve
reserves are paid for with taxpayer
money and it would be very easy for
someone anyone to find out that this
wasn't an actual preserve especially a
u.s. government who doesn't take kindly
to that kind of impersonation and
airplanes oh the air plants sure they
feed us some nonsense about paying off
some guys and the government to make it
a no-fly zone but here's the thing
no-fly zones are almost exclusively
reserved for government or military
reason and even if you did manage to
secure one there's no way you could
enforce it against military or
government aircraft and that's ignoring
that civilian aircraft accidentally fly
over no-fly zones often not to mention
that there's no way to make a no-fly
zone big enough that you wouldn't hear
the planes even if you couldn't see them
all of this to say there's no possible
way no matter how rich you are how hard
you try to keep this little colt in the
Prairie a secret from those outside or
more importantly those inside the not so
friendly confines and since the entire
central conceit of the movie rests on it
how about we handcraft another 56 M
night Shambo
no one has thrown these bananas out yet
rodents of unusual size I don't think
they exist room spinning Jane too much
we sat down there on company orders to
get this thing which destroyed my crew
gather your bravery no cell phone
reception no traffic cameras both
someplace but one goddamn weekend when
it can't globally position mass so the
evil things from my past are kept close
and not forgotten myself in a bar this
criminal has plagued my family for
nearly 20 years he's a ruthless
adventurer and a con artist who preys on
mentally people sick old ladies I
probably fix them too you alone will
follow the road follow the yellow brick
road
[Music]